I can't choose between Natalie or
Madison it's to tax okay well first of
all it's good to see you yeah
via the internet via the zoom how are
you doing with all of this and what do
you kind of make of everything that's
happening right now I don't know I mean
it's all it's all so so crazy obviously
I feel like everyone has the same exact
reaction to it it sucks but I feel like
I feel like it's like at least me
personally like I figure I really needed
like a break from everything and like
really slow down it feels like if the
best thing to compare it to is it feels
like summer break as a kid or like you
have all this time off and you're
literally just there's nothing to do
it's exactly it was like who are you
quarantined with Natalie so Natalie's my
sistent and then Taylor my other step
she comes by and then and then Ilya Ilya
just moved here like a week or two ago
he's my friend from my hometown and he's
coming out here to help us at work so
he's here full-time now
[Music]
inside I put a little gift for you it's
a check for $10,000 I do want to talk
about your newest video you gave away
Xboxes you gave away cash and you get
away freaking cars right yeah how does
this all sort of happen so in a lot of
my videos we give back to a lot of
people so during this quarantine and
this whole pandemic there was a lot more
people reaching out the norm about like
things they need it like whether it was
help of mortgages or oh yeah they just
needed some cheering up or something
like that so yeah so I reached out to
this company I work with a lot yeah and
they said that they would love to do
something we use this thing called the
community app and it was and we had
people text us there and we got a couple
hundred thousand people to text us and
that way we could a hundred thousand
people texted you how many people that
250 yeah two or 50,000 people which is a
lot we rented an RV and we went through
like all of LA and like you know part
different parts of California and we
would look at every city that we were
stopping by and we were seeing who
needed what so whether someone did like
some cheering up we'd get them like an
iPad or like an Xbox or somebody didn't
like help with their mortgage we'd give
them like a check for $10,000 I think we
gave a little over nineteen people a
check for $10 was cool there's a lot of
fun in the meantime I have I have been
hooking up with Natalie so yes if you
guys are perfect I do have to ask you
though because at the very beginning of
that video you did make a joke about
Natalie right yeah and you guys are
hooking up now she wishes we get a
Natalie reaction can we flip the camera
yeah now what do you what do you say she
said absolutely not okay so no truth to
that you were just trying to like toy
with everyone's hearts I was even told I
think it should be obvious at this point
that there's never gonna be a time when
only have not a burger even if this
pandemic lasted 25 years and we were
stuck inside it's never going to happen
I did hear that the new roommate how do
I say his name Illya Illya yeah oh yeah
he had a crush on Natalie growing up is
that right I think he had yeah he
confessed his love to her a couple
months ago I think everybody around me
really really likes Natalie and they all
have crushes on Natalie it's like it's a
really bizarre thing maybe I know her
too well yes crazy how are they
adjusting to being roommates that into a
love connection there no I think for
Elliot's gone out the window because
he's coming to help us with work and one
thing that's more important and than
anything is a business so I think he has
put all his feelings to the side just
yeah improve his work life well how do
you feel about people constantly
shipping you with Natalie or other
people I don't know I don't I don't I
don't really care I don't know should I
have a reaction where I'm like upset I
mean it's like the Internet such an like
it's an obvious place like you make one
video with one it's always been like
this won't be anytime like you interact
with one female or somebody that people
think that like you look cute with and
then everyone you know either assumes
you're dating or they want you today
like that's just our that's just how it
all works
yeah well sir you feed into that a
little bit because you posted an
Entertainment Tonight video on your
tik-tok where we wondered if you were
beaten yeah yeah that was great
that was such a win thank you for uh I
found that video and I was like are they
dating and then the next thing I know
it's like a video and then your chick
talking about it you know small circles
for me right now
yeah funny it's like it's like I don't
know what the video was but they're
sparking dating rumors because we may
have to talk together and I was like
hell yeah Wow one tick tocking them I'm
already in a relationship
yeah but you did post another recent
video like questioning if you and
Madison were dating so Wooster now that
they're not dating
no I'm not I'm betting that dating now
okay in general are just not Madison I
can't choose between Natalie and Madison
it's too fast
[Music]